[SIDE CONVERSATION]
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So if people are
in the room, we're
going to start with
the next talk by Alex.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
SPEAKER 1: So I'm happy to
introduce Alex, Alex Chen.
He's working at
the Creative Lab.
He has a background in
interactive design, music.
And he's going to talk
about some of the work
he's been doing around
teachable machines.
ALEXANDER CHEN: Hi, everybody.
Excited to be here.
So I work at Google.
I'm mostly based in New
York and in Cambridge,
the other Cambridge.
And I work on a team
called Creative Lab.
You know, my background is in
a little bit of everything,
a little bit of design,
a little bit of coding,
and a little bit of music.
But I'm definitely not a
machine learning expert.
So in some ways,
part of the projects
that I'm going to show you
are sort of my first dipping
my toe into this
world of machine
learning in collaboration
with a lot of other people.
So I have a slide with
my now six-year-old.
Because, as you'll see,
the way that he thinks,
obviously, kind of fills my day.
And it actually kind of seeps
into a lot of the projects
that I'll be sharing today.
And the project that
I'll be showing, just
to skip ahead a little bit,
is called Teachable Machine.
And I'll give some
background on it first.
But in a nutshell, we
released this last year.
And it sort of lets you train
a machine learning model right
in your browser
using your webcam.
And I'll get more
into what this means.
But I wanted to kind of zoom
out before I got into this one
and talk about some
of the motivations
behind some of these
recent projects
and also give credit and
thanks to all the people
that kind of helped with this.
It's built with something
called deeplearn.js
made by Nikhil and
Daniel on Martin
and Fernanda's
team in Cambridge.
And I'll talk more
about this tool
that they made, and also, a
collaborative effort with a lot
of teammates in New York.
Also, a lot of projects
that preceded this.
A lot of you know Rebecca's
work in Wekinator.
This was very much
inspired a lot of what
we did with Teachable Machine.
And a really high
level motivation
behind a lot of this--
I love this quote
from Seymour Papert--
is, you know, he says,
"mathophobia blocks many people
from learning anything
they recognize
as math, although they
may have no trouble
with mathematical knowledge."
And this is something that
I'm really passionate about.
And so playing in this
area of machine learning
is something that I kind
of care a lot about.
And I think about that
and kind of get it
every time I watch my
now six-year-old playing
with origami.
You know, he doesn't even--
he's still learning his
numbers in kindergarten.
But he's, like, incredibly
advanced at origami.
He could follow
instructions like this
to do these cool things
faster than I can.
And he's kind of playing with it
and figuring out all this stuff
even before he can
kind of articulate
all these mathematical
geometry concepts.
So in a lot of ways, another
metaphor that I like to use
is, you know, I'm trying
to teach him piano.
I have a background in
playing a lot of music.
But I often find
that he makes music
more like this-- you
know, taking apart
all the instruments that
I have sitting around.
And in some ways, this
picture kind of shows a lot
of the motivation behind
the projects that I'm
going to share as how can
we make machine learning
and math feel a little bit
more like this for everyone?
A lot of the projects that
I'll share live on a site
called AI Experiments.
And these projects
that we've created
are more of thought starters.
You'll see they're kind of
these little toys that hopefully
inspire other developers
and other people
to kind of run with them.
So we kind of put
them out in the world
as these little
thoughts starter toys.
And I'll show a couple of these.
The first one I want to show
is this little experiment
that we collaborated with a
friend of ours, Carl McDonald.
And part of the motivation
behind this was, you know,
I'd heard about, you know,
these visualizations techniques
that all my friends here at
Google were telling me about--
t-SNE, running it on data.
But I thought one of the
tests Kyle showed really
made it feel more
accessible through sound.
So what he had done was
he had run, you know,
a t-SNE algorithm on I think
up about 14,000 sounds.
That's what you're seeing there.
[SLAM]
[BAM]
[COUGH]
I'll turn that
down a little bit.
And--
[SLAM]
[TUMBLE]
You know, I don't really have
a background in data science.
And this was the first
time that I really
felt like I wanted to like
dig into this data set.
You know, like, what
is this island--
[SLAM]
[SHRILL WHISTLE]
--of little sounds over here.
That's the kind of
shrill whistle island.
And, you know, what is this
purple island over here?
[PLINKS]
That's the kind of
plinky, plinky sound.
[PLINKS]
[TUMBLE]
And I think by adding this layer
of sound and music onto data,
it suddenly made me want
to become a data scientist.
Like, you know, if somebody
had asked me, like,
oh, you want to comb
some data for the day?
And, you know, you
could really get lost.
You know, what's
this teal island?
[METAL CLANGING]
Kind of strange staticky world.
And, of course, as the
toy aspect, you know,
we decided to throw a
little drum sequencer.
[SQUEAKY HORN]
So we sort of made
the drum sequencer
like the world's biggest
drum machine out of this.
[SQUEAKY HORN]
Another project we did
kind of almost as a Save
As of that project, you
know, is around bird sounds.
So we talked to
Kyle about dropping
in little snippets
of bird sounds
into a similar algorithm.
[HAWK CRIES]
And what I really
like that he arrived
at here was he
showed me this, you
know, graphic that
he had exported
of all these tiny
little spectrograms--
[COUGH]
--the visualizations--
[BIRD CALL]
--of these sounds.
And I'd never really seen
spectrograms used in this way.
[CHIRPS]
And what I found interesting
was even if you're not
interested in sound, I feel
like it makes it more accessible
by seeing these tiny
little visual thumbnails.
Because you can kind of be
like, ooh, what's those?
You know--
[CHIRPS]
--sort of your visual
half of your brain
is linking in the similarity.
And even when you
zoom out, it's amazing
how you can kind of scan and
find these little islands--
[SQUEALS]
--through the spectrogram.
You can also search.
So if I type owl, you can--
[HOOTS]
--kind of find the
little islands of sound
that have come out of this.
[HOOTS]
So there's the kind of
ooohing area of the owl.
[CHIRPS]
Or that's the--
I'm not sure.
Not a bird expert.
And this is a
collaboration with--
Cornell Lab of Ornithology let
us use their data for this.
And, you know, we
open source all
of these things hoping that
somebody will kind of grab
this stuff and kind of run with
it and figure out what else
to do with it.
Probably one of the
silliest projects
I've ever been involved
in which I don't have time
to demonstrate is
called Giorgio Cam.
Oops.
Oh.
[SPEAKING ON TUTORIAL IN
BACKGROUND]
Oh, that's OK.
I think it's my--
we'll see the project later.
It's my tutorial voice
on the website, which
I heard somebody's opened up.
But this project, you know,
you can try it at home.
It's at g.co/giorgiocam.
And it's really the
world's simplest demo.
It's just image recognition.
But when you take a
picture of something,
there's a Mad Lib
format where it
tries to take the
labels of what it's seen
and tries to make
a song out of it.
Very silly thing, but
the thing that we really
liked about this was
that it kind of changed
the feeling of image recognition
from being something that's
being done to us to something
that's like in your hand
that you can kind of
walk around the room
and take pictures
of things and kind
of almost start playing
with the algorithm.
Like in this case, you know,
you point it at a globe.
Is it going to get globe,
or is it going to get world?
You know, you point it at
different string instruments.
And, you know, it says,
pluck string instruments.
It's kind of a fun, surprise way
of combing and probing at what
image recognition can do.
And, of course, the most
popular project among these
was something that one of my
teammates Jonas came up with.
And he collaborated with a team
that's actually half of them
are based here in Zurich
as we saw earlier.
And it was called Quick, Draw!.
I know a lot of you
have probably played it.
So you basically
draw, and the computer
kind of plays a
game of Pictionary
with you trying to run
stroke recognition on what
you're doing.
But the really interesting
part of this whole project
was after you play
the game, we kind of
wanted to find these
educational moments where
you saw the drawings
that you got
and the ones that
it didn't get right.
So this was a game I
just played earlier.
For some reason, it didn't
recognize this top one
as a power outlet.
I'm still not sure why.
And we just tried to use these
moments just to kind of, like,
tickle the brain a little bit.
You know, said it thought
your drawing looked more
like these, like a
calculator, oven, calendar.
And it shows examples
of other power outlets
that other people have drawn.
I think this one has probably
modeled after a European outlet
with the kind of diagonal up
ones, which kind of tickled
our brains.
After this project, Jonas
and a bunch of others
said, oh, we have to open
source this data set.
Because so many people
are talking about this
and wanting to comb it.
So Jonas set up
this effort to open
source this data set in
collaboration with a lot
of other people here at Google.
And I'll just-- whoops.
I'll just click this link,
because it's incredibly fun.
I feel like a lot
of these projects
have just made me realize
how much data can be
a really fun thing to explore.
So even here-- I'll close my--
the windows.
We made sure that when
we put out this data
that it wasn't just a
link on GitHub that you
had to be a developer
to get into,
but that anybody who
comes to this website
can literally scroll this page.
Jonas built this web page
so that if you see this,
tiny little scroll bar, I think,
has 147,000 outlets on it--
so that everybody, even
if you're not a coder,
could essentially
become a data scientist
by combing through this thing
and finding different outlets
people have drawn.
It's amazing how well
you can comb things.
Like, this person decided
to just write power outlet.
You can find all kinds
of interesting things.
And all kinds of fun
stuff came out of this.
You know, we talked a little
bit about the Facets tool
that was made by someone here,
James, as well as the Big
Picture team.
They used Quick, Draw! as
sort of the introductory data
set for this new
tool because there's
something about seeing these
drawings that really kind of,
even if you're not
a data scientist,
makes you kind of
curious to play
with this tool, which was a
great collaboration with them.
And these kind of overlaid
images were really fun.
For some reason, in Italy I
guess three scoops is kind of--
when you close your eyes
and picture ice cream--
three scoops.
And even people
outside of Google--
so this was an amazing article.
I think it was probably a
collaboration behind people
who are interested in
culture and that the way
that different cultures,
obviously, shape our instincts.
And they just had the most
wonderful interactive thing
on the front of just
to say, draw a circle.
And which way did you
choose to draw it,
clockwise or counter-clockwise?
And then you're suddenly
drawn into this entire article
about culture and drawing.
And that kind of leads us up
to our most recent experiment
that I just wanted
to demonstrate.
And I'll do it live
as I walk through it.
OK.
So there is a tutorial
which actually has my voice
kind of talking you through it.
So I'll just do it sort of live.
ALEXANDER CHEN IN TUTORIAL:
This is an experiment--
ALEXANDER CHEN: Oops, sorry.
I should have said
Skip Tutorial.
OK.
So you kind of land
on this web page.
And the webcam is here.
And what you can do
is train a class,
train your first, you know,
image classifier here.
And if you hold the green
button down, and I move around,
it's now kind of grabbing
frames from my webcam.
So it's grabbed, you
know, 120 frames.
I'll explain the cat
GIF in just a second.
Well, basically, on the
right side is outputs.
So it's going to trigger
different outputs based
on what class is triggering.
For, you know, people who
are interested in the kind
of details of this
design, you'll
notice right now it says
100% confidence green.
That was kind of
a design decision
we debated a little bit.
And it almost feels like
an error in this design.
But we kind of thought it
was important to reveal
what the machine learning
algorithm does when you only
train one class.
It's incredibly kind of naive.
It's like, well, out of all
the things you've shown me,
I choose green because
you haven't even
moved onto the next one yet.
So, obviously, you need
to train a second one.
So we'll try this.
If I-- it's going to be tricky.
Here, I'll step out of frame.
So now, if I'm in frame,
you know, it chooses green.
And if I'm out of frame,
it chooses purple.
And for the last one, I'll
just raise this mic in the air.
So now, it's triggering
between all three.
So I think if I raise
my mic in the air--
and, of course, we hooked
it up to different sounds.
So--
[CHIRPS]
--right now, it's playing
a bird sound, birds.mp3,
when it's the green class.
[CHIRPS]
[ELECTRIC GUITAR]
It plays an electric
guitar solo right now
if I step out of frame.
[CHIRPS]
[SAD HORN]
And, of course, we
have speech over here.
COMPUTER: Hello.
ALEXANDER CHEN: So we could,
you know, say anything we want.
You know, so I could have
it say, where'd you go.
See if it says that right.
COMPUTER: Where'd you go?
Hello.
Yeah.
Where'd you go?
Hello.
ALEXANDER CHEN: And you know,
even these little things,
you know, on that where'd you
go one, like, I'd kind of been--
my day is mostly, you know,
begging the real machine
learning researchers
at Google to just keep
re-explaining this
machine learning stuff
to me over and over.
And it wasn't until I played
with that speech thing
that I kind of
finally understood
this idea of labeling
is essentially--
you know, it's a human activity.
And I've essentially labeled
that state "where'd you go"
arbitrarily.
But, you know, the
machine has no concept
of person in frame,
person not in frame.
It has no, you
know, understanding
of that sort of thing.
So, you know, just playing
with these little moments
sort of gives you a
little bit of insight
into how classification works.
So I wanted to show
some of the things
that people have
actually done with this.
And I'll show some examples
of things that can be done.
So this is one of the demos
that I tried early on is just--
[ELECTRIC GUITAR]
--playing air guitar
solos with your hand.
[DRUMS]
So you can train it on
different hand gestures.
[ELECTRIC GUITAR]
[DRUMS]
This is kind of a fun test.
You know, I like doing
origami with my kid.
So I wanted to see
if I could kind of--
[CHIRPS]
--do a little
origami classifier.
[ORGAN]
[CHIRPS]
But it was fun doing this test.
Because, you know, I made--
[ORGAN]
Oh, yeah.
[CHIRPS]
[ORGAN]
It's incredibly fast.
So part of the cool
technical aspect of this,
as I mentioned
before, is it uses
a library called deeplearn.js.
And it's all happening
locally in the browser.
So your images aren't
actually ever sent
to servers, which is why,
you know, you can kind of put
the ghost in and out
of frame, and it really
switches pretty quickly.
And I kind of felt like even
as I played with this stuff,
I accidentally
found myself doing
little, like,
science-y experiments,
like choosing to make both
of those origami things
white with a couple
of black dots on them.
Like, could it really
tell the difference?
And try to do the same
experiment with, you know,
different colored
pieces of paper.
A couple other things--
this was one I trained on,
some drawings that my kid did.
COMPUTER: Jellyfish.
Submarine.
Jellyfish.
Millennium Falcon.
ALEXANDER CHEN: This was
a fun experiment, too.
Because he'd
actually drawn two--
I asked him to
draw a few things.
And I asked him what they were.
And then I put the labels
into the speech thing.
He actually drew two jellyfish.
And I trained it on one.
And it sort of
understood the other.
So it sort of decided that
among the three things
it was able to figure
those three out.
This is something somebody
did with their house plants.
This is a project
somebody did online
where they, I think
with their kid,
had a toy train set going by.
And they sort of
uploaded their own sounds
into the source code.
So that as the train went by, it
would trigger different sounds.
But the most exciting
thing is that, you
know, we put these things
out as thought starters,
so that anybody can
kind of riff on them.
So Dan Shiffman with the team,
who's here today, kind of
recreated this in
their new framework,
so that anybody could kind
of build this from scratch.
And Jonas also kind of put
out a boilerplate example,
almost stripped down of
all the UI and stuff,
so that anybody could
kind of riff on top of it.
And we did find a lot of
people playing with this stuff.
So here's a ninth grade
class where, you know,
the kids were kind of playing
with some sort of image
classification.
This one was really cool.
So I found this on Twitter.
These fifth grade
girls were actually
creating what they called
a smart security system.
And from what I can deduce,
they had different friends
stand in front of it and
classify on each of them.
So as the teacher says, they
gathered the data, trained it,
and voila.
And it's kind of amazing.
I wish I could have
been a fly on the wall
to, like, hear the questions
that, hopefully, this provoked.
You know, like I
would have loved
to see their debug process.
Like, hey, how come it's
not working on my friend?
Maybe we should have that
person jump in on this
now and add a new class.
And I think it really
kind of tickles
the brain in certain
ways of, you know,
as you play with this
thing, you start to realize,
like, is it picking
up on the faces.
What if you turn the laptop?
Is it more picking
up on the background
that you trained it on?
You can quickly
uncover these sort
of problems and opportunities
with this stuff.
This was something I just
found this morning actually.
So I found this teacher
who is, I think,
building sort of a city
simulation using Lego robots.
So they've sort of built
a whole city with sensors.
And as a side activity--
it's not actually
linked up to that--
they decided to
cut out road signs.
So you'll see they've
made a stop sign.
And they're actually
going to use
Teachable Machine to train it to
recognize different stop signs.
I think they're still trying to
figure out how to hook the two
things up together.
But it's kind of amazing
that they're essentially
exploring these, like,
really big questions.
Apparently, they
actually had an assembly
about the ethics of smart
cities and all kinds of things,
which is an sort of amazing
teacher figuring out
to do this.
And, of course, the thing
that we saw earlier today
is maybe one of my favorite
things that I've seen.
A really inspiring
coder in Portland is--
his friend just
suffered a stroke.
So he actually took
the boilerplate code
for Teachable Machine and is
training it to move a mouse
cursor with a gesture.
So he's working
on that right now.
So I just thought I would close
with this quote from a teacher
that I really admire that says,
"Mathematics is fundamentally
about patterns and
structures rather
than little manipulations
of numbers."
And so I think
back to this as we
try to build, like, tools
for interpretability
and kind of being
able to investigate
and kind of poke and
prod at these things.
It's like, can we
get to this feeling
that you are essentially
playing with it without being
intimidated by it?
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE].
Question?
He decided I was too
biased to that side, so.
[LAUGHTER]
No?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
It's a switcheroo.
I moved from the center, because
I knew you would ignore people
in the center.
ALEXANDER CHEN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Amazing.
I've taken all these notes.
And I'm really curious
about this great gift
of all of the draw
with Google IP
that you've put into
the open domain.
Could you just talk
us through the process
by which you persuaded a
publicly listed company
to do that, and what
you learned from it,
and kind of what internal
attitudes were and so on?
Because it's a great
achievement to do that.
ALEXANDER CHEN: Yeah, it
was a big team effort.
I think I, obviously,
did very little of it.
It's sort of this magic
of knowing how to--
it was, you know, producers
talking to lawyers talking
to designers talking to--
but I think it's sort of a
story of, like, little steps
one at a time.
We essentially put out-- you
know, Jonas hacked together
the Quick, Draw!
Toy in, you know, under
a week, just that kind
of delightful moment
of, wouldn't it
be fun to play Pictionary?
And we kind of took
these steps up there.
So I think part of it
was the public interest
in the game I think persuaded
other people at Google as,
like, oh, yeah,
let's definitely--
if people are asking for it
and other machine learning
researchers are asking for it
and want to explore this data,
then let's do it.
So-- no magic
formula for doing it.
But it really was sort of like
a little one step at a time.
We had no grand plan all
the way from the beginning.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about what I can only
really describe in British terms
as, time to penis, which is--
when in England being given the
opportunity to draw something,
that's one of the first
things that gets drawn?
And so can you talk
about managing data sets
which may or may not be full
of the things that you want?
And how much of that
plays or has an impact
on the success of a project?
ALEXANDER CHEN: Yeah.
So an interesting
story about, you
know, as we were working on
getting that data set out,
kind of makes me [INAUDIBLE]
a lot of the talks today.
But I feel like a
lot of design now
is in the writing and
the framing of the thing,
so a lot of--
you know, the website
itself of this big scrolling
page of drawings was designed,
you know, quite quickly.
But then, you know,
the sentences above it
were part of the design process.
And, you know, it'd
suddenly be all of us,
whether you're a designer,
a producer, a writer,
being like what is the right
way to talk about this data set?
It makes me think about the
sort of co-creation IKEA effect
that Cliff talked about earlier.
The sentence that we
arrived at the top
was something along the lines
of if you see something,
flag it as inappropriate
because it will make it better
for everyone, which is true.
But also, in this
sort of like, hey,
we all want this data
set to be out here,
so we kind of need your help
to not ruin this for everyone.
You know, like we sort of
openly acknowledge that you're
going to find some stuff here.
And we kind of, I think, landed
on that true, honest thought
that, hey, we need
everybody's help
and being very honest
that we didn't have the--
we also didn't want to
overly curate ahead of time.
Because for researchers, they--
some researchers might actually
need a really authentic data
set.
So it's sort of that
language of co-creation
which helped us sort of land
that feeling of about having
this data set out there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Alex.
Could you explain
a little bit what
other metadata is associated
with these data sets?
Because you talked
a little bit about,
you know, you can use it to
study culture, for example.
So what other data is
there associated with that?
ALEXANDER CHEN: I'd have to
ping Jonas after this call
and get you a detailed list.
But, yeah, as you could
see, they at least
have, like, country associated
because that [? quotes ?]
article from
different countries.
Beyond that, I don't know
off the top of my head,
but hopefully, enough
to be interesting.
But I can ask him and
find out an exact list.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right now,
people are generally
happy to provide their training
data for these kind of things,
because they're fun, and
interesting, and novel.
That won't long be the case.
How do you foresee the
future of experiments
like that when people recognize
that this is essentially labor
you're asking them to provide?
ALEXANDER CHEN: Yeah, I mean,
that's an interesting also--
Quick, Draw!, it was
essentially, you know,
all going into one
collective data set.
Whereas, Teachable Machine, it's
all happening on your laptop.
So, essentially, the sort
of thing that you've trained
is all sitting on your computer.
So it is an interesting
kind of fork
in the road where I could
imagine a world where
if, you know, that
kind of classifier I'd
made for my kid's
drawing, would that
be something that I could kind
of grab and share and post?
And so I think that idea of
you owning a little model
that you've made
was very much what
we wanted to go for
with Teachable Machine.
But we haven't quite
gotten to that.
That's almost the second
phase of that hopefully.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Alex.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: : The next
speaker is Patrick Hebron.
He is an [? associate-- ?]